[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils ont laissé gagner ces partis valérie
benaïm cet homme qu est ce qu un canif
bon petit chien un petit chien un pardon
[Applaudissements]
si ces droits justement tu sais pas
drôle vous appuyez 1 c'est un couple qui
s'approche d'un puits d'accord y'a le
mari car garde
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le mari en garde fait un souhait est une
pièce la femme regarde tourner dans le
puits elle se noie le mec dit oh ça
marche vraiment bien qu'animée cudi
pinocchio lorsqu'il lâche une caisse
geppetto parce que vient d'essayer de
défis dont gilles verdez pourquoi les
bélugas sont ils une espèce en voie
d'extinction
parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de belushi et
là il faut vraiment essayer de faire et
amanda est aussi vraiment si vous ne
rigolez pas rigoler panier ne leur fait
pas plaisir ils ont l'habitude c'est un
enfant c'est que le public ait son papa
papa pourquoi on n'a qu'un oeil pas
pourquoi on n'a qu'un oeil à me cache
pas la cohue
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
annan qui rencontre un autre homme dans
un pré c'est quoi ton nom bob dylan
n'oubliez pas le buzzer ses deux potes
qui se rencontrent et bien qu'il ya
l'autre est ici restait que 15 minutes à
il restait que 15 minutes à vivre
qu'est-ce que tu ferais belle mais qu'il
y avait moi je viserai tout ce qui bouge
et toi moi je voudrais pas de la sibérie
à sa race à ce que je vais dire moi
qu'est ce qu'un requin sur une
bicyclette un trois-roues intrants vous
comme il connaît toutes les bactéries
alors qu'est ce qu'un vin qui vient
d'acheter en étant un mollusque car
c'est un petit calamars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a beaucoup parlé de france
télévisions tout à l'heure à l'aîné j'ai
deux petites histoires de ces sous forme
de devinettes aya est ce que vous savez
que les stops ce que font les femmes de
grand reporter après après avoir fait
l'amour
non elles vont chercher leurs maris à
l'aéroport ce qu'on a parlé tout à
l'heure des effectifs de france
télévisions est ce que vous savez
combien de personnes travaillent à
france télévisions de fond 1500 dhs
non la moitié environ
[Applaudissements]